[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and on calling me where
turn diverging and this culture lacks
the superstition abortion legacies and
they powered people cultures people who
are fighting for independence
[Music]
one who loved to ride
[Music]
if you've ever thought you needed my
crown and colored carpet for your birth
you could come diseases and take a
birthday C cannot see
here is no weapons Oh
[Music]
to cosplay as a warframe to the ultimate
meta you can do it and see this if you
need news to back codes for other
customizations for companions you can
come to see this
[Music]
if you need gross fish heads for some
reason you could come here and proudly
just look if you're an Isis fan that
probably would look great in your
orbiters so in warframe you guys have
been leveling weapons for years and
applying from a set of hundreds of mods
but you never got to make your own
weapons from parts
[Applause]
[Music]
so the off strong at hawks anvil the off
fronds we'll be presenting a new
component based weapon system for the
game this is the beginning of this
system that will have other
manifestations we'll talk about that
later on the show every aspect of this
weapon the strike the hilt sorry the
strike the grip all of these things
affect not only the stance that you use
when you when you're using the weapon
but the way it does crit and the damage
types and then there's the balance which
has you know special effects and that
sort of thing
so hawks anvils gonna be very
interesting for you guys the coolest
part which is very easy but very
interesting is you'll get to name your
weapon for a change
[Applause]
you can see here Scott's been careful to
put in our VIP tent Oh hanging out your
relay you know I don't know if you snort
this or you add it to cooking there's
some powders back there that are
interesting and then I can hear people
talking in the front row we want to try
to make this game feel less of the
scenes of less jumping to the ship and
back and jump into the ship and back
oh this Megan Megan's gonna be playing
with it awesome awesome we've got a
fellow here who of course has a problem
that he needs a tunnel to solve I owe
that dude our tessellation plants
kinetic motivator has failed we have
many in need of fresh water need oats if
you would risk a journey across the
plains my clade will make it worth your
while this I swear
[Applause]
the Grenier have one such motivator at a
camp I have marked for you borrow it for
us for the children
so khonsu's got a problem of course
these guys are scavengers and getting
water purifications a big problem for
them so we can probably run a mission to
help out ponzu kind of see how he reacts
but oh hey Mac thanks for coming it's
got a crazy colorful monster that's
really cool
oh very good not very good of course
however I think what would be much more
interesting as if we didn't have to
return to our ship
that was very anticlimactic I mean is
there a whole bunch of these
[Music]
should I open
[Applause]
all right well thank you for that
I just unclenched this is the plains of
Eidolon this is while we were walking
from the relay we streamed in three
kilometers square space of gameplay for
you guys to experience caves and hidden
camps things to explore a sense of
freedom that we've never seen in
warframe before
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that mountain behind there is is a game
play space it isn't a backdrop that left
green your building is an outpost that
looks down upon a dig site they have
been building temporary encampments here
excavating for artifacts of the old
[Applause]
go die Rebecca
you guys have been used to running
missions like a rat in a maze and this
is completely different and killing
birds double-plus good this is an
ancient battlefield where the sentience
tried to destroy this organ tower and
failed and died so their corpse the
corpse of this one sentient is littered
throughout the landscape which is
obviously what the green are interested
in oh is that a bug what is that if you
can locate a grineer camp we may be able
to recover the component the Austrians
require
you can see a big rendering upgrade that
we've been working on for three months
two distances we've never had to do
before particular rays time of day new
water shading
what are you doing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
now there's a whole set of new resources
involved in the warframe landscapes
feature one of them is fish so all of
the things that we showed you and see
just about the weapon crafting there's
other stuff would show at the end as
well
this creates and a feedback loop a
positive feedback loop of you guys going
exploring this landscape selected
resources and I guess I got spear
fishing down that just goes it's cool
however because we have a large
landscape now it doesn't mean that we
want to kind of go slow and and admire
the daisies we still feel that warframe
is a game about speed and high mobility
so Rebecca you don't mind
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh No
[Applause]
[Applause]
don't die Rebecca you got this
this landscape is you guys know about
how earth is working for right become
it's sometimes Dave sometimes night the
rendering tech and the art for this is
the built up continuous day/night cycles
we'll do a demonstration that per second
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so diary
[Music]
I'm detecting sentient energy unlike
anything I've seen before
[Music]
sunsetting
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]